il ya donc je dis on avait évoqué le
départ des candidates et candidats de
télé réalité pour dubaï magali berda
c'est un petit peu la reine des abeilles
à la reine des abeilles elle c'est la
reine a et des candidats de télé réalité
ça veut dire celles qui les gèrent tous
voilà donc et est apparu très énervé
puisque ils sont réservées de ce qui a
été dit dans l'émission ça leur a pas
plu du tout alors regarde jeudi dernier
on vous parlait de toutes ces stars de
télé-réalité qui s'en vont à dubaï parce
qu'elles en ont marre d'être cambriolé
est adressé et voilà ce que kelly et
benjamin avait dit sur le plateau le
train d'internet du passé cas pas
d'impôts voix des docks d'un porte voix
cela n'a visiblement pas plu à ses
expatriés 2.0 qui y sont allés de leur
réponse s'avère nous étions obligés de
partir à dubaï pour éviter les
cambriolages ça avait fait le buzz sur
le plateau violet et pas sur un stade
toute la journée laure muller rolex
lormont leur pognon il serait pas qu'il
y ait là d'accord et la dalle est
d'accord bien sûr et ce soir quand tout
montrer leur vie de leur rue de leur
maison de leur appartient ce qui a fait
sortir les nouveaux dubaïote de leurs
gonds fond la tuque dj jack est là deux
balles 50 derrière je sais même pas
comment tu t'appelles
mais en fait
d'abord tu redescends ma cocotte et là à
faire de la musique avec des jeux
électroniques en fait je fais même pas
dj du tout un besoin déconner on
connaissait une personne une personne
qui a été cambriolée qui change
totalement de pays qui paraît existe
trois delormeau franchement tu me déçois
tellement oublie pas d'où tu viens tu
viens du mad mad mon pote
l'afer est parti loin au point de
critiquer tous les participants de
l'émission j'ai l'impression que sur le
plateau de thé pmp là j'ai pas vu des
animateurs chroniqueurs adultes mais
juste une bande de gamins et heures des
réseaux sociaux
tous seront des tests en fait bon alors
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on parle de
tpm paix jusqu'au bout du monde
blague à part vous comprenez ce coup de
gueule alors est ce que vous comprenez
leur coup de gueule le coup de gueule
des candidats de télé réalité parce que
quand on regarde après la vidéo après je
vais pas et des fonds de ça mais c'est
vrai qu'on peut on peut comprendre aussi
sûr on peut les rejoindre sur un truc
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas se réjouir que
des personnes et été cambriolée en effet
été maltraités j -louis sur le fond je
suis pas en désaccord avec eux mais la
forme
l'agressivité non mais ça c'est pas bien
franchement la manière dont six graves
vous n'aimez pas l'agressivité la
manière dont ils parlent de kelly jeu
tavera désobligeants leurs sabots et ça
c'est quand on voit la wii qui dit non
alors moi ce que je peux dire c'est que
j'ai trouvé ça injustement
ça a été trop loin je trouve c'est ça
ouais je trouve que ça va trop loin
parce que j'aurais préféré qu'elle me
reproche de ne pas assez me connaître en
télé réalité et de ne pas savoir
vraiment ce qui s'était passé dans leur
vie parce qu'à aucun moment je vais
cautionner les cambriolages en fait en
voyant cette vidéo l m'a insulté mais au
final j'ai eu là j'ai réussi à avoir de
la peine pour elle quand bien même elle
maintient aussi parce que je n'étais pas
du tout au courant de son histoire et
j'ai envie de la vie je me serais permis
de lui souhaiter du mal ou pas que ce
qu'elle peut me reprocher par contre oui
c'est ne pas être au courant du dos
magali berda qui est là petit peu la
porte parole il ya la porte il ya le
porte parole du gouvernement
l'incursion de télé réalité mais ce
qu'il faut dire c'est qu'on a affaire à
une maman qui vient de se faire gazer et
qui a eu son bébé de quatre mois qui a
été gazés donc c'est traumatisant et
quand vous ne connaissez pas quand tu
connais pas le sujet le problème c'est
que tu peux pas te permettre de dire des
choses parce que derrière il ya en fonte
qui est très grave
personne ne doit cautionner un
cambriolage ou un braquage locaux c'est
à dire que il montre trop sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que c'est leur vie
et toi même kelly tu sais que tu es une
star montante d'instagram tut tut
cartonne tu es une star montant des
taxes à ce qu'on s'est dit tout à
l'heure avec justement je fais partie de
ces personnes qui en montre de plus en
plus et c'est ce que je voulais
expliquer c'est que on se risque à
femmes et tous j'en fait parti aussi
alors bougez rock intelligent avoir
votre réponse vous parce que vous les
grondements réponse à ce sujet mob avec
vous emballer les emballer qui oui je
m'emballe est complètement je n'ai pas
je veux pas répond gilles c'est pas
méchant mais non mais je n'amènerais pas
parler 107 ans voilà l'histoire des mois
ça mérite pas tout ça et à la voilà tout
ce qu'ils ont ils ont ils ont été un
petit peu loin aux yeux
le truc c'est que ils ont réagi sur le
truc c'était un peu son ton sa blague on
peut comprendre qu'ils étaient
traumatisés ils sont tout à fait c'est
pas qu'ils nous ont fait un petit peu de
peine d'ailleurs sur la vidéo même mois
de gaz elle m'a fait de la peine ça mais
c'est vrai que ils ont été un peu trop
loin sur kelly et sur benjamin je trouve
ou là surtout à tester un pétage de
plomb qui démontre l'immaturité des deux
personnes sur snapshot sur instagram
voulaient assister à une téléréalité
leur télé réalité avec leur lot
d'insultés et d'outragé perso c est
terrible c'est en mesure de notre avis
mais si on est traitée de bande
d'abrutis est débile alors dans ce cas
là ça a presque rien c'est un peu alors
que j'aimerais avoir l'avis de géraldine
maillet y répond avec leurs codes de la
téléréalité moi je les défends à mort en
fait jazz et thibault moi je suis
vraiment de leur côté je trouve qu'en
fait c'est honteux de dire que sous
préfet
mais je connais leur argent leur voiture
je suis d'accord oui ce qu'ils
méritaient c'est absurde c'est comme si
on dit il ya une schiste en trottoir
elle en mini jupe c'est bien fait son
travail voilà tu donc ça je trouve que
ça et qu'on avait quoi je vous dire je
pense que sur le plateau pensez même pas
ça parce que ça s'est tellement vite on
s'est dit voilà franchement ce qu'on a
ressenti mois alors écoutez j'étais pas
dans l'émission j'ai trouvé que c'était
quand même un peu et vous avez raison là
dessus alors j'aide à fait d'accord avec
vous c'est bien pour eux mais voilà
quelle revanche
je vais pas dire grand-chose de plus je
voudrais juste m'excuser auprès des
personnes que ça a fait pleurer que saha
blessé et voilà je mate je m'attendais
pas à ça et je voulais pas ça très vite
oui ce n'est pas non plus aplatir moi je
trouve que c'est très triste à face à
levante y répondre oui c'est vrai qu'il
aurait alors moi je vois plein qui pas
du tout mais je trouve qu'ils ont été
trop loin
oui je le paie réalité je ne cautionne
pas du tout la manière dont il a parlé à
benjamin oui et à kelly voilà maintenant
fin de l'histoire je vais vous dire
franchement j'espère qu'il aura arrivera
que des bonnes choses parce que
heureusement n'a rien contre les ponts
double fond limites de la peine parce
que si ce qui leur arrive et ça c'est
grave mais voilà mais on va pas se
mentir on va pas faire un débat de deux
heures là dessus donc merci voulait dire
oui oui je voulais remercier kelly parce
qu'elle a été quand même fair play s'est
excusé auprès de jazz et je suis sûr que
jazz acceptera t excuse et mercia alors
les frères jazz à la cave des excuses
merci merci à lui